do me a favor will you not uh have 20
years go by before we talk again I know
and you know what one reason I I gotta
come visit you is because you're moving
your show to New York you're going to be
in my old Studio where we did late night
from 93 to 2009 yeah so for 16 years I
was in that place that place is near and
dear to my heart that's where I
am that's where we met I know and you
said I'll see you in 20 years
I really couldn't believe it been 20
years I was like geez you said I'll see
you in 10 albums sucker
um but uh yeah Letterman was in that
studio before me and he did his iconic
show there there's a lot of they told me
the history of it yeah Tom Snyder was
there interviewed John Lennon in that
room uh that is a very famous Studio
that has magical Mojo so I'm really
happy that you're going in there it
makes me happy too I'm really happy too
yeah and I'm happy for you also you've
just had it's funny I have this odd
thing I've mentioned it to some other
people on the podcast where when I meet
these very talented people when they're
very very young and then they go on to
all the this greatness I always have
this weird sense of uh quasi-pride like
yeah she did a good job like I'm your
uncle or something you know what's so
funny so I talk especially like I mean
I'm 41 now so like I'll talk to artists
that'll come on they're like early 20s
and I'm like I always wonder because
I've been that kid on a show like the
same thing so I'm like I wonder like who
you know if I'm still doing this and
they come around like a decade like
that's crazy to because it is like
you're watching someone
kind of grow up that's that's incredible
yeah that's a moment even with my artist
like on the voice for my first season
like with Brent like I just watching her
grow up it's it's interesting you do
take a certain Pride even though you're
not even involved you're not doing
anything with them they're like you do
take a sense of Pride I think yeah well
uh the album chemistry will I think when
this drops it doesn't drop it drops no
I'm saying the podcast I'm so confused
about what to say because it falls with
a bit of a thud yeah it tumbles out it
drops it's cool yeah by the time this
well don't tell me it's cool okay
because then it's not because then it's
not thank you oh my God wait can I say
something real quick do you I just found
this out in a podcast yesterday
do you all know I'm look I'm gonna sound
like an idiot do you know like do you
know before anyone answers what Netflix
and chill is like do you know what that
is yeah I do yeah what do you think it
is well I I think it's Let's uh let's
get it on as the kids used to say you
didn't know that did y'all know that
yeah it's like a it's like a it's like a
way of saying let's do it yeah my friend
was like yeah that's like gonna text
like you up and I was like yeah wait
what I have been saying I'm more of a
Netflix and chill girl like
no no no Kelly that means no it doesn't
mean what you think I oh I am aware as
of like 12 hours ago I was like but I
didn't know I'm like oh my God I have
been saying like oh I'm like a Netflix
and chill person like I just thought it
meant yes it's kind of like it's almost
like a booty call thing to say yeah like
let's just watch Netflix and chill is
code for yeah it'll be on in the
background my other one I had no idea
and I have been out here for like a
minute to go and I know I'm like low-key
I'm like Netflix and chill kind of girl
and they're all like all right girl
kind of a Hulu and screw guy
[Applause]
ah be down for either but like I just
I'm up for the occasion but like I just
didn't know I'm just a peacock and just
a peacock yeah
it's kind of sets itself up at least
until not well Kelly I hope I see you
again uh soon you are uh well you're
everything you were when I met you 20
years ago you're you're just still
incredibly talented obviously that
doesn't go away but you're a very warm
real person and you're funny and you're
still yourself you're still the person
that ran down the street after those
people that ran out on the tab and um so
and I know you've been I know you've
been through a lot but uh I I know
better times are coming so and I'm happy
for you man they're already here yeah
very good yeah Kelly Clarkson everybody
thank you